اذا مجموعه من المعطيات اليوم والمستجدات
لو سمحت ضعها في
سياقها الابرز هو ان المنطقه تنتظر وصول
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه بلينكن الذي من
المفترض ان يصل في وقت لاحق اليوم ويجري
مباحثاته مع القياده الاسرائيليه غدا وقد
يعود للمشاركه مجددا في اجتماع لمجلس
الحرب والطاقم الوزاري الامني المصغر مثل
ما فعل في المرات الاربعه السابقه هذه
زيارته الخامسه الاربعاء سيكون هنا في رام
الله للقاء الرئيس الفلسطيني لكن الابرز
هو ملف مباحثاته مع الجانب الاسرائيلي هذا
الملف تحديدا هو يشمل عده او هذه الاجنده
عده امور ابرزها انه هناك نقطتان من
الخلافات بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
تتعلقان اولا بمساله رؤيا اسرائيل ل اليوم
التالي للحرب واداره قطاع غزه هذا في حال
ان انتهت الحرب بما تشتهي اسرائيل بطبيعه
الحال والقضيه الثانيه تتعلق بمساله
انتقال اسرائيل التي بدات للمرحله الثالثه
ولكن يبدو انها ليس وفق ما كان متفق عليه
مع الامريكيين بهذا الخصوص الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي انسحب من داخل احياء شمال
قطاع غزه لكنه توقف عند مشارفها الولايات
المتحده كانت تريد ان ان يكون ابعد الى
منطقه الحدود وان يتيح للمواطنين
الفلسطينيين الذين هجروا ونزح من مساكنهم
في الشمال الى الجنوب ان ي يتيح لهم
العوده هذا الموضوع ما زالت اسرائيل ترفضه
وفي نفس الوقت ارادوا ان يكون المرحله
الثالثه تشمل ايضا جنوبي وسط وجنوبي
القطاع لكن اسرائيل اعلنت انها ستواصل
حربها هناك بضراوه اما بالنسبه لليوم
التالي للحرب فهذا كان موضوع خلاف وسجال
داخل الكب بيت
الاسرائيلي واشتهرت حول ذلك ما جرى في
اجتماعه يوم الخميس ليلا ونتنياهو وجدها
فرصه للتنصل وعدم طرح الموضوع للبحث خشيه
من الوزراء الاشد تطرفا وعنصريه داخل
حكومته خاصه التوام سموتريتش وبن كبر من
الصهيونيه الدينيه وعظمه يهوديه الذان
حذرا من انه اذا ذهب الى ذلك سيترك
الحكومه عاد سموتريش مجددا وقال بانه
يطالب باحتلال كامل لقطاع غزه واقامه
مستوطنات فيها واعطى مثالا غير حقيقيا عن
ان ما وصفها بالارهاب انتشر في شمالي
الضفه الغربيه طول كرم وجنين لانه ليس
هناك استيطان علما ان الاستيطان يخنق
منطقه طول كرم وكذلك غربي منطقه جنين وا
بالاضافه لهذا كله هناك التصعيد الذي يشير
اليه المتحدثون نم الاسرائيليين بين الحين
والاخر